It's hard. After "On the Road Again" and "Six Days On the Road" and "Hit the Road Jack" and "Roadrunner" and "Born to Run" and "Running on Empty" and "Life in the Fast Lane" and "Lost Highway" and "Highway One Revisited." After "Let's Get Away From it All." After Easy Rider and Thelma and Louise and Lost in America and too many road movies to name or even remember. After Jack Kerouac and Route 66. And as long as we're at this, after Huck Finn and The Journals of Lewis and Clark. After all that it is hard for an American to just hit the road without some expectations.
这很难。在《On the Road Again》、《Six Days On the Road》、《Hit the Road Jack》、《Roadrunner》、《Born to Run》、《Running on Empty》、《Life in the Fast Lane》、《Lost Highway》以及《Highway One Revisited》之后。在《Let's Get Away From it All》之后。在《逍遥骑士》（Easy Rider）、《末路狂花》（Thelma and Louise）、《迷失美国》（Lost in America）以及多到数不清、甚至记不住的公路电影之后。在杰克·凯鲁亚克（Jack Kerouac）和66号公路之后。既然说到了这儿，还得加上哈克·费恩（Huck Finn）和刘易斯与克拉克的日记（Journals of Lewis and Clark）。经历了这一切之后，美国人很难在没有任何期待的情况下就这样踏上旅程。
Take Jamie. After his mother died, after three months of visiting her in the hospital and three years in which she'd been sick, he hit the road, in the car that used to be hers.
以杰米为例。在他母亲去世后，在经历了三个月去医院探望她以及她患病的三年后，他开着那辆曾经属于她的车踏上了旅程。
I kept trying to be, like, you know, what is the realization I'm going to come to? Or what is the feeling that I'm going to settle on? And that was what I kept feeling was, like, am I feeling something? Am I experiencing something?
我一直在试图，你知道的，我在想我会得出什么感悟？或者我会定格在什么样的感受上？我一直感到的就是，我在感受什么吗？我在经历什么吗？
Really? You felt like, OK, I'm on this big road trip. I'm supposed to have a revelation.
真的吗？你觉得，好吧，我正在进行一次盛大的公路旅行。我应该有所顿悟。
Yeah. That's what I thought. You know, I was hoping that I would, yeah, be somewhere, I'd step out of the car and experience the grandeur of the place and just be like, yeah, this is what life is. And this is, like, my mom dying. And this is, like, where I am in my life. And, you know. But it didn't happen like that.
是的。我是这么想的。你知道，我当时希望我会，是的，到达某个地方，我会走下车，体验那个地方的宏伟，然后感觉，没错，这就是生活。这就是我母亲去世这件事。这就是我目前所处的人生阶段。而且，你知道的。但事情并没有那样发生。
Any road trip is going to feel longer than you think it will. And you'll be tired and you won't get a meal exactly when you're hungry. You never find a bed exactly when you want to go to sleep. And you're probably not going to find out what it is that you got on the road to find out in the first place. And you know all that. You know all that going into it.
任何公路旅行都会感觉比你预想的要长。你会感到疲惫，无法在正好饿的时候吃上一顿饭。你永远无法在正好想睡觉的时候找到床位。而且你很可能根本找不到你最初踏上旅程想要寻找的答案。你心里都清楚。在开始之前你就知道这一切。
And you still, we all still bind to the cliche about road trips. That what a road trip stands for is hope. Hope. That somewhere, anywhere, is better than here. That somewhere on the road I will turn into the person that I want to be. I'll turn into the person that I believe I could be, that I am. And, come Memorial Day, we hit the road. You and me and our whole great nation, with high hopes and no expectations for the future.
即便如此，我们所有人仍然被公路旅行的陈词滥调所束缚。认为公路旅行代表着希望。希望。认为某个地方，任何地方，都比现在这里要好。认为在路上的某个时刻，我会变成我想要成为的那个人。我会变成我相信自己能成为的那个人，那样的我。于是，在阵亡将士纪念日到来时，我们踏上了旅程。你、我，以及我们整个伟大的国家，带着崇高的希望，对未来却毫无预期。
And, to hasten the journey, we bring you now this hour of radio. Today, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Road Trip. Act One, Busman's Holiday. Dishwasher Pete loved riding the bus from city to city until one last seven day trip that took him off the whole deal.
为了加速这段旅程，我们现在为你带来这一小时的广播。今天，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台（Public Radio International），这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目主题：公路旅行。第一幕，公交司机的假期（Busman's Holiday）。洗碗工皮特（Dishwasher Pete）曾经热爱乘坐公交车穿梭于各个城市之间，直到最后一次为期七天的旅行让他彻底放弃了这个念头。
Act Two, Merci. How do you even say that? Mare-see? Merci. Can a road trip in Europe save a marriage? The answer is with one case study.
第二幕，Merci。这词儿怎么念？Mare-see？Merci。在欧洲的公路旅行能挽救一段婚姻吗？答案就在这一个案例研究里。
Act Three, On the Road in a Tuxedo. At the age of 92, comedian George Burns was still traveling all the time. Margy Rochlin briefly traveled with him. What it is like when being on the road has been your job for decades.
第三幕，穿着燕尾服上路。92岁高龄的喜剧演员乔治·伯恩斯（George Burns）依然一直在奔波。玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）曾短暂地随他旅行。当在路上奔波了几十年成为你的职业时，那是一种什么样的感觉。
Act Four, Paw Paw for Jesus. Cheryl Trykv achieves what everyone wants when they hit the road. She actually finds adventure, and it is not pretty. Stay with us.
第四幕，为了耶稣的波波果（Paw Paw for Jesus）。谢丽尔·特里夫（Cheryl Trykv）实现了每个人上路时都想要的愿望。她真的找到了冒险，但这并不美好。请继续收听。
Act One, Busman's Holiday. Regular listeners to our program may remember Dishwasher Pete who travels from state to state washing dishes and publishing his zine Dishwasher. Usually he only stays in one place for a few weeks. And then he takes the Greyhound bus to the next town. Lately he's been living in Portland. But he was only too happy to get back on the bus.
第一幕，公交司机的假期。我们节目的常客可能还记得洗碗工皮特，他从一个州跑到另一个州洗碗，并出版他的杂志《洗碗工》。通常他只在一个地方停留几周。然后他就会坐灰狗巴士去下一个城镇。最近他一直住在波特兰。但他还是很高兴能再次坐上巴士。
I like riding Greyhound. Over the last eight years I figure I've ridden at least 100,000 miles on Greyhound. In total, about four solid months of my life have been spent cooped up in their buses. I would consider it my home away from home, if only I had a home.
我喜欢坐灰狗巴士。过去八年里，我算了一下，我至少坐了10万英里的灰狗巴士。总共，我生命中大约有整整四个月的时间是被关在他们的巴士里度过的。如果我有一个家的话，我会把这视为我的第二个家。
What I like most about Greyhound is how long it takes to get anywhere on the bus. Airline passengers love to complain about the five excruciatingly long hours it takes to fly from coast to coast. But on the bus that same distance takes three full days to cover, which is what I think is about the perfect amount of time for such a trip. And unlike airplane flights, no movies are shown on Greyhound, no headsets handed out, no free magazines available. No waitresses force bags of peanuts on you every five minutes. On the bus, passengers are largely left alone with their thoughts.
我最喜欢灰狗巴士的一点是，坐巴士去任何地方都要花很长时间。飞机乘客喜欢抱怨横穿海岸需要那令人抓狂的五个小时。但在巴士上，同样的距离需要整整三天才能跑完，我觉得这对于这样的旅行来说恰到好处。而且不像飞机航班，灰狗巴士上不放电影，不发放耳机，没有免费杂志。没有空姐每隔五分钟就强迫你吃袋花生。在巴士上，乘客大多可以独自沉思。
I have this theory about people who ride Greyhound. About how, as we sit on the bus for hours and days, waiting to reach our destination, we travel in what I call a transitional state, thinking about where we're coming from and where we're going to. I know I do. And from my talking to other people on the bus, I know many others do as well.
关于乘坐灰狗巴士的人，我有一个理论。关于当我们坐在巴士上几个小时甚至几天，等待到达目的地时，我们处于我所谓的“过渡状态”，思考着我们从哪里来，要到哪里去。我知道我是这样。从我和巴士上其他人的交谈中，我知道许多人也是如此。
For example, this one route I've ridden a lot goes south through Crescent City, California, home of the Pelican Bay maximum security prison. I rode next to this guy who'd been locked away for 14 years and had just gotten out. Across the aisle from me was a teenager with a buzz cut on his way to boot camp. We talked for a while, but mostly we just sat and thought about the different places we were headed.
例如，我经常走的一条路线是向南经过加利福尼亚州的克雷森特市（Crescent City），那里是鹈鹕湾（Pelican Bay）最高安全级别监狱的所在地。我坐在一个刚出狱、被关了14年的人旁边。我走道对面是一个剃着寸头、正要去新兵训练营的少年。我们聊了一会儿，但大部分时间我们只是坐着，思考着我们要去的不同地方。
For a long time I've been wanting to tape record the stories I've heard on the bus, to document this phenomenon that I've been trying to figure out. So I was pretty excited when This American Life offered to send me on a Greyhound trip with a fancy tape recorder and a seven-day Ameripass. For a week, I could wander any Greyhound route I chose and test my theory about the bus.
很长一段时间以来，我一直想录下在巴士上听到的故事，记录下我一直试图弄明白的这种现象。所以当《美国生活》提出派我进行一次灰狗巴士旅行，并配备一台高级录音机和一张七天的Ameripass通票时，我非常兴奋。一周时间里，我可以漫游任何我选择的灰狗路线，去验证我关于巴士的理论。
So I packed up a loaf of peanut butter and jelly sandwiches and a bunch of bananas and stepped on a Greyhound.
于是我打包了一条花生酱果酱三明治和一堆香蕉，坐上了一辆灰狗巴士。
I spent the first 10 hours traveling down the coast of Oregon. I was so eager to talk with the other passengers I stayed awake all night even though everyone else was sleeping. It wasn't until we stopped for breakfast in Crescent City that I was finally able to strike up a conversation. Steve was about 50 years old, sported a bushy beard and wore an olive green army jacket. A large wooden crucifix dangled from his neck. He said he was an itinerant preacher and that Greyhound was his chapel.
我花了最初的10个小时沿着俄勒冈海岸旅行。我太渴望和乘客交谈了，以至于尽管其他人都在睡觉，我却整晚都没合眼。直到我们在克雷森特市停下来吃早餐时，我才终于搭上话。史蒂夫大约50岁，留着浓密的胡须，穿着一件橄榄绿的军用夹克。脖子上挂着一个大大的木制十字架。他说他是一位流浪传教士，而灰狗巴士就是他的礼拜堂。
Well, I just preach in my own time. Not any specific times. And usually try to avoid audiences when I do speak because that way I reduce the possibilities of rejection or mockery. [LAUGHS]
嗯，我只是在有空的时候传教。没有特定的时间。而且通常尽量避免观众，因为这样我可以减少被拒绝或嘲笑的可能性。[笑声]
You avoid audiences. Then who are you talking to?
你避开观众。那你是在对谁说话？
Well, see, I believe in the transmission of voice or spirit can transmit 360 degrees into the world times 360 degrees.
嗯，你看，我相信声音或精神的传递可以向世界360度乘以360度地传导。
And Greyhound's conducive for your traveling ministry?
灰狗巴士对你的这种巡回牧师生活有帮助吗？
Well, in the fact that I do not have my own privacy, like in a private vehicle, there becomes an either intermeshing or clashing of spirits like on a crowded-type Greyhound. Sometimes things are more harmonious, and other times people pick and poke and they solicit a reaction.
嗯，事实上，因为我没有像私人车辆那样的隐私，在拥挤的灰狗巴士上，就会出现精神的交织或碰撞。有时事情更和谐，而有时人们会挑衅和刺探，引诱出反应。
So normally your preaching on the bus would come with you just talking to the person sitting next to you?
所以你平时的巴士传教就是和你旁边坐着的人说话吗？
Most of my preaching is done by myself, just speaking into the air, though, without another human being being there. You might be one of the first human beings that's ever really listened to me or acknowledged that in my presence.
我的大部分传教都是独自完成的，只是对着空气说话，尽管周围并没有另一个人在场。你可能是第一个真正听我说话，或者意识到我存在的人类。
Steve's ministry is not limited to the teachings of Christ but also included a healthy dose of praise for natural medicines, like cannabis and opium. I thought I was agreeing with him when I said that it did seem ridiculous that pharmaceutical companies simply sold nature back to us. But Steve took offense and pulled out a bottle of Anbesol, which he described as 60% grain alcohol plus benzocaine.
史蒂夫的传教不仅仅限于基督的教义，还包括对大麻和鸦片等天然药物的大力推崇。当我表示同意他的观点，即制药公司简单地把大自然卖回给我们这事听起来很荒谬时，我以为我在附和他的观点。但史蒂夫对此感到冒犯，并掏出了一瓶安贝舒（Anbesol），他称之为60%的谷物酒精加上苯佐卡因。
Which is a chemical, as a chemical similar to the naturally occurring cocaine. And so if a person likes the cocaine--
这是一种化学物质，类似于天然存在的可卡因。所以如果一个人喜欢可卡因的话——
What's it for?
这是用来做什么的？
Well, it's just a little topical anesthetic which is like a local number. And so they talk about toothache and things of that nature. Certainly not a central nervous system relaxant like the opium poppy. Which I consider more of a valuable plant. Because of its pain relief but--
嗯，这只是一个小小的局部麻醉剂，就像局部麻木一样。人们用它来治疗牙痛之类的问题。肯定不是像鸦片罂粟那样的中枢神经系统镇静剂。我认为那更像是一种有价值的植物。因为它有镇痛作用，但是——
Chug a lug.
干了。
Just a little nip. Just a little nip now.
只是一点点。只是一点点。
So is that numbing your whole mouth now?
所以你现在整个嘴都在麻木吗？
Well, it takes about 10, 15 seconds. Actually, there is an immediate effect, but, yes, it is actually, believe it or not, numbing and very pleasant.
嗯，需要大约10到15秒。其实有立竿见影的效果，但是，是的，信不信由你，它确实让人麻木，而且非常舒服。
Steve continued talking, but it became increasingly difficult to understand what he was saying as his speech slurred. By the end of our 15 minute talk he told me it was the longest conversation he had in the last three and a half years. Then Steve got on the northbound bus bound for Portland and I continued on to San Francisco.
史蒂夫继续说着，但随着他说话开始含糊不清，越来越难听懂他在说什么了。在我们15分钟谈话结束时，他告诉我这是他三年来进行的第一次长谈。然后史蒂夫上了开往波特兰的北上巴士，我则继续前往旧金山。
From San Francisco I rode 10 hours to Los Angeles, sitting next to an 11-year-old kid that didn't want to talk to me. At the Hollywood bus station I saw a bus headed for San Francisco and figured, what the heck? Maybe I'd get lucky on that bus. So I spent the next 10 hours retracing my route back north, sitting beside a guy who slept the whole way.
从旧金山我坐了10个小时到达洛杉矶，坐在一个不想和我说话的11岁小孩旁边。在好莱坞巴士站，我看到一辆开往旧金山的巴士，心想，管他呢？也许那辆车上我能走运。于是接下来的10个小时我原路北上，坐在一个一路都在睡觉的人旁边。
I had to wonder, where were all the talkers, all those chatty passengers that usually sit next to me and share their stories about where they're coming from or going to?
我不禁怀疑，那些爱说话的人都去哪了？那些通常坐在我旁边，分享他们从哪里来、要去哪里的故事的健谈乘客都去哪了？
In Reno I switched to a bus route I've always been curious about, the one that headed south through old mining towns down to Las Vegas. My attempts to find out who rode that particular bus led nowhere. I approached the other half dozen passengers one by one. But no one would talk to me.
在里诺，我换乘了一条我一直很好奇的巴士线路，那是向南穿过老矿镇前往拉斯维加斯的路线。我试图找出谁在坐那辆特定的巴士，但一无所获。我一个接一个地接近其他六个乘客。但没人愿意和我说话。
On the bus from Las Vegas to Flagstaff, Arizona, I asked the woman sitting next to me if I could record our conversation for the radio. She acted like I was nuts. "You want to talk to me about Greyhound for the radio? What radio station is that?" "Well," I explained, "it's a show that's on different stations in different cities." "What station is it on in Los Angeles then?" she asked. "Los Angeles, I'm not sure." "You want to record me for the radio, and you don't even know what station it is? Yeah, right," she's scoffed. "Give me a break."
在从拉斯维加斯到亚利桑那州弗拉格斯塔夫的巴士上，我问坐在旁边的女人能不能为了广播录下我们的对话。她表现得好像我疯了。“你想为了广播跟我谈灰狗巴士？那是哪个电台？”“嗯，”我解释说，“这是一个在不同城市的电台上播出的节目。”“那它在洛杉矶是哪个台？”她问。“洛杉矶，我不确定。”“你想为了广播录我，结果你连是什么台都不知道？得了吧，”她讥笑道。“放过我吧。”
She alerted the other passengers around us that I was trying to pull something over on her. Soon I was verbally assaulted from all sides, the butt of everyone's jokes. I put the tape recorder away and stared out the window. My enthusiasm for this trip was rapidly dwindling.
她提醒周围的其他乘客我在试图骗她。很快我就遭到了四面八方的口头攻击，成了大家笑话的对象。我把录音机收起来，盯着窗外。我对这次旅行的热情正在迅速减退。
At a rest stop I slinked away from the pack of passengers who were smoking their cigarettes and ridiculing me and stood off by myself. Maybe I'd been wrong. Maybe there wasn't anything significant on the minds of Greyhound passengers after all. When the smoke break ended, I reluctantly got back on the bus.
在休息站，我从那一群正在抽烟、嘲笑我的乘客中溜走，独自站着。也许我错了。也许灰狗巴士乘客的心里根本没有什么重要的事。当烟休结束时，我不情愿地回到了巴士上。
On any bus there's usually some sort of outcast, like the drunk guy who smells like urine or the woman babbling to herself. Then it dawned on me. With these dorky headphones on my head, this foot long microphone in hand, trying to get people to let me interview them about where they're going, it was me. I was the weirdo on this bus.
任何巴士上通常都有某种边缘人，比如满身尿骚味的醉汉或自言自语的女人。然后我恍然大悟。戴着这副蠢耳机，手里拿着这一英尺长的麦克风，试图让人接受采访谈谈他们要去哪里，那个人就是我。我是这辆巴士上的怪人。
Hello? Well, I guess since nobody else will talk to me on this bus and there are only a couple people on this bus and we've got about nine more hours to go and it doesn't look like anybody else will be getting on the bus because we are in the middle of the desert. So I may as well talk to myself.
喂？好吧，我想既然这辆车上没别人愿意和我说话，而且车上只有几个人，我们还要走大约九个小时，看起来也不会再有人上车了，因为我们在沙漠中央。所以我还是自己跟自己说话吧。
We are somewhere in the desert. I can see we're traveling under a clear blue sky. I can see about 30 miles. And a whole lot of dirt, rocks.
我们身处沙漠的某处。我可以看到我们在晴朗的蓝天下行驶。我能看到大约30英里远的地方。全都是灰尘和岩石。
I guess I didn't have much more to say than anybody else on the bus.
我想我并没有比巴士上的任何人有更多的话要说。
Um--
呃——
All these years I've boasted of being some sort of hardy Greyhound passenger, impervious to all those things that many people complain about. The seemingly never ending rides, the annoying passengers, the claustrophobia. I mean, I sat next to a guy vomiting on himself and it's no big deal. I sat across the aisle from people having noisy sex and it didn't bother me. But now, on this trip, Greyhound was starting to get to me.
这些年来，我一直吹嘘自己是个坚韧的灰狗巴士乘客，对许多人抱怨的那些事情免疫。那些看似永无止境的旅程、烦人的乘客、幽闭恐惧症。我是说，我坐在一个呕吐的人旁边，也没什么大不了的。我坐在吵闹着做爱的人对面，也没困扰我。但现在，在这次旅行中，灰狗巴士开始让我受不了了。
On the bus to Phoenix, I found myself wedged between the window and a guy who took up way too much of my seat. I tried to sleep for the first time in days but found that I couldn't. My whole body was sore. I had shooting pains in the back of my thighs. My back ached. I had a headache. The baby in front of me cried the whole way. The toddler behind me got smacked around for not sitting still after having been pumped up on candy. I was becoming increasingly claustrophobic. I was beginning to lose it.
在去凤凰城的巴士上，我发现自己被夹在窗户和一个占据了我太多座位的家伙中间。我几天来第一次尝试睡觉，却发现睡不着。我全身酸痛。大腿后侧有刺痛感。背部剧痛。头痛欲裂。我前面的婴儿一路都在哭。我后面的幼儿因为吃多了糖不肯坐好而被扇了耳光。我开始感到越来越幽闭恐惧。我快要崩溃了。
Normally I survive long bus rides by concentrating on my destination, but now I didn't have a destination. I wasn't really going anywhere. How could I expect to find anyone in the transitional state when I wasn't even in transition myself? Maybe this was the problem with the whole mission. I had ceased being a regular Greyhound passenger. I was an outsider.
通常我通过专注于目的地来熬过长途巴士旅行，但现在我没有目的地。我哪儿也没去。当我自己都不在过渡中时，我怎么能指望在别人身上找到那种过渡状态呢？也许这就是整个任务的问题所在。我已经不再是一个普通的灰狗乘客了。我是一个局外人。
I stood in line for the bus to Las Cruces, New Mexico, trying to calm down. I thought I was in control until I watched a mother drag her kicking and crying toddler across the bus station by the kid's hair. I snapped. I couldn't take it. I couldn't handle being constantly surrounded by so many people anymore. I sure wasn't feeling at home like I usually do.
我排在去新墨西哥州拉斯克鲁塞斯的巴士队伍中，试图冷静下来。我以为我控制住了情绪，直到我看到一位母亲拽着她那个又踢又叫的孩子穿过巴士站，抓着孩子的头发。我崩溃了。我受不了了。我再也无法忍受一直被这么多人包围了。我显然不像往常那样感到自在了。
I stepped out of line for the Las Cruces bus. I had to get home. Sadly, Portland was still a 36-hour ride away.
我离开了去拉斯克鲁塞斯的队伍。我必须回家。可悲的是，波特兰距离这里还有36小时的车程。
At the Arizona-California border, a new passenger sat down across the aisle from me. Not needing any more abuse from strangers, I resisted my initial temptation to talk with her. A couple miles down the road I watched her pull a Polaroid photo from her purse, stare at it for a half minute, and then tuck it back in her purse. A minute later she had the photo out again and this time I snuck a peek and saw that it was a photo of her sitting in the lap of a guy wearing prison garb. Since she had boarded the bus in a prison town, I realized she had probably just visited a jailed boyfriend or husband.
在亚利桑那州和加利福尼亚州的边界，一位新乘客坐在了我走道对面。不想再受到陌生人的侮辱，我抑制住了最初想和她交谈的冲动。行驶了几英里后，我看着她从包里掏出一张拍立得照片，盯着看了半分钟，然后又把它塞回包里。一分钟后，她又拿出了那张照片，这次我偷看了一眼，发现那是一张她坐在一个穿着囚服的人膝盖上的照片。由于她是在一个监狱城镇上的车，我意识到她可能刚刚探望了一个在监狱里的男朋友或丈夫。
Now she had to sit on the bus for who knows how many hours and dwell upon the person she had just left. At last, I thought, the one person I had been looking for on this whole trip. Someone in transition. Someone who could help me prove my theory about the bus. Her name was Lisa. And she was just as suspicious of me as any other passenger had been. But she did consent to let our conversation be recorded.
现在她必须在巴士上坐上不知道多少个小时，回味着她刚刚离开的那个人。终于，我想，我整个旅程一直在寻找的那个人。一个处于过渡状态的人。一个能帮我证明我关于巴士理论的人。她叫丽莎。她和其他乘客一样对我充满怀疑。但她同意了让我录下我们的对话。
Arizona. Yeah. Nothing great.
亚利桑那州。是的。没什么特别的。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
No.
没有。
The conversation didn't get very far. She gave only one or two word replies to most of my questions. Eventually she ended up asking me the majority of the questions. After a couple of awkward minutes, I put the microphone and tape recorder away. She stared at her photograph some more while I watched the desert in the fading sunlight.
谈话没进行多久。对于我的大多数问题，她只给出一两个字的回答。最终她反而开始问我大多数问题。在尴尬的几分钟后，我收起了麦克风和录音机。她又盯着她的照片看，而我看着夕阳下的沙漠。
A half hour later, after the bus had darkened and people dozed off, Lisa tapped me on the arm and told me she had inherited powers from her grandmother. Powers with which she could grant me any wish I desired. For this service she would only charge me $5.00. "At my shop," she said, "usually I charge $10, uh, $20 for a wish." She said it just like that. "$10, uh, $20."
半小时后，当车厢变暗，人们睡着后，丽莎拍了拍我的手臂，告诉我她从祖母那里继承了力量。凭借这些力量，她可以满足我的任何愿望。这项服务她只收我5美元。“在我的店里，”她说，“通常我许一个愿要收10，呃，20美元。”她说得轻描淡写。“10，呃，20美元。”
Well, $5 for a wish seemed like a bargain so I started counting up the hundreds of nickles I had won in a Las Vegas slot machine. But she said it would only work with a $5 bill. I didn't have any fives, but I did have a 10. "A 10 will work," she said.
好吧，5美元一个愿望看起来很划算，于是我开始数我在拉斯维加斯老虎机赢来的几百个镍币。但她说只能用5美元的纸币。我没有五美元的，但我有一张十美元的。“十块也行，”她说。
I followed her instructions, folding the bill into a little ball and handed it to her. She squeezed it in her fist and said, "Now make a wish. But you can't tell anyone what it is." So I made a wish. Then she told me to tell her my second and third wishes. That these wishes were important, too, but not as important as the super important first wish. Well, in my state I only had one wish that I needed fulfilling, so I just made stuff up for the merely important second and third wishes, wishing for better health and a new romance.
我照她说的做了，把钞票叠成一个小球递给她。她把它攥在拳头里，说：“现在许个愿。但你不能告诉任何人。”于是我许了一个愿。然后她让我告诉她我的第二个和第三个愿望。说这些愿望也很重要，但没有第一个超级重要的愿望那么重要。嗯，在我当时的状态下，我只有一个愿望需要满足，所以我就随便编了第二个和第三个重要性一般的愿望，许愿身体健康和一段新恋情。
On the dark bus she whispered across the aisle, assuring me that I was now in better health and that I could expect a new love in my life. Then she asked me to tell her my super important wish, my number one wish. "But you told me not to tell me anyone," I said. "You can tell me," she said, "but don't tell anyone else."
在昏暗的巴士上，她在我对面耳语，向我保证我现在身体更健康了，我可以期待生命中一段新的爱情。然后她让我告诉她我的超级重要愿望，我的第一愿望。“但你刚才告诉我不要告诉任何人，”我说。“你可以告诉我，”她说，“但别告诉别人。”
So I told her I wished I wasn't riding the bus anymore. "Oh," she said. "You're tired of riding the bus. I can see it in your face that you're very tired. You have a kind face." She whispered about my face and described how tired I looked for five minutes, mentioning three times that while I might be laughing on the outside I was really crying on the inside. But I wasn't laughing, not even on the outside.
所以我告诉她，我希望自己不用再坐巴士了。“哦，”她说。“你厌倦了坐巴士。我能从你的脸上看出来你很累。你有一张善良的脸。”她低声谈论着我的脸，描述了五分钟我看起来有多累，并三次提到，虽然我表面上可能在笑，但内心却在哭。但我根本没在笑，甚至表面上也没有。
When she was done I watched her slip my 10 in her pocket. Meanwhile, I was still on the bus.
当她说完时，我看着她把我的十块钱塞进了口袋。与此同时，我依然在巴士上。
Dishwasher Pete will be putting out a new issue of his zine Dishwasher in a few weeks. Grab a pen. If you send him a dollar, you can get it. At P.O. Box 8213, Portland, Oregon, 97207.
洗碗工皮特几周后会发布他的杂志《洗碗工》的新一期。准备好笔。如果你给他寄一美元，你就能收到。地址是P.O. Box 8213, Portland, Oregon, 97207。
[MUSIC - "GREYHOUND THEME IN E MINOR" BY IAN LYNAM AND PAUL IONNATI]
[音乐 - "GREYHOUND THEME IN E MINOR" BY IAN LYNAM AND PAUL IONNATI]
Act Two, Merci. A road trip can be a profound test of any relationship. After all, expectations are high, everybody's looking for a good time. And at the same time you're in circumstances that can make anybody irritable, probably because you're together all the time. All the time. Because of all this, a road trip can save a marriage or destroy it. We bring you this case example told by Carmen Rivera and Candido Tirado at the Nuyorican Cafe in guess which east coast city.
第二幕，Merci。公路旅行是对任何关系的深刻考验。毕竟，期待很高，每个人都想玩得开心。与此同时，你所处的环境可能会让任何人变得烦躁，大概是因为你们时刻都在一起。时刻。正因为如此，一次公路旅行可能会挽救一段婚姻，也可能摧毁它。我们为你带来卡门·里维拉（Carmen Rivera）和坎迪多·蒂拉多（Candido Tirado）在纽约的Nuyorican咖啡馆讲述的这个案例，猜猜是在哪个东海岸城市。
A couple years ago a friend of Carmen's decided to get married in Italy. The friend was already married, but the friend had not told her parents. So she decided to get married again on her anniversary in Italy with her parents present.
几年前，卡门的一个朋友决定在意大利结婚。那个朋友已经结婚了，但她没告诉她的父母。所以她决定在结婚纪念日那天在意大利再次结婚，并让父母出席。
So we think it's a good idea, but we're not really sure if we want to go. She invites us to the wedding and we're not really sure because we had gone to Italy the year before and we're kind of not getting along. We're not communicating and we're kind of angry at each other. And it was this atmosphere of a general malaise in the house.
所以我们觉得这是个好主意，但我们不太确定是否想去。她邀请我们参加婚礼，而我们不太确定，因为我们前一年去过意大利，而且相处得不太好。我们没有沟通，互相之间有点生气。家里笼罩着一种普遍的不安感。
Malaise? [LAUGHS]
不安感（Malaise）？[笑声]
That's what it was. What do you want to call it?
就是那样。你想怎么称呼它？
Fighting. Changing the TV channel. I mean, we fought about everything.
吵架。抢电视遥控器。我是说，我们为每件事争吵。
Yeah, but that was like a malaise.
是啊，但那就像是一种不安感。
OK. Whatever.
行吧。随便。
OK. So we're in this malaise. We haven't decided yet. And we get a phone call from Paris, from a friend of ours, [? Malika ?], who invites us to stay in her house in Paris. And we tell her about the wedding in Italy and she goes, well, why don't you come stay with me and then we'll all go together to Italy? So I think that's a great idea. We can kind of be with friends in Europe--
好吧。所以我们处于这种不安中。我们还没决定去不去。然后我们接到了巴黎一个朋友[马利卡]的电话，她邀请我们去她巴黎的家住。我们跟她说了意大利婚礼的事，她说，那你们为什么不先来跟我住，然后我们一起去意大利呢？我觉得这是个好主意。我们可以和朋友在欧洲待着——
I need to interrupt here. When she says Paris, see, you don't get the idea. This is an obsession. Ever since I know her, she says, I want to go to Paris, I want to go Paris.
我得插一句。她说巴黎的时候，你看，你不明白。这是一种痴迷。从我认识她起，她就说，我想去巴黎，我想去巴黎。
That's not true. Don't exaggerate.
那不是真的。别夸张了。
Every movie that has Paris in the backdrop, we see. Every magazine article, "Look, Candido, Paris." So I decided to quench this thirst.
每部以巴黎为背景的电影我们都看。每篇杂志文章，“看，坎迪多，巴黎。”所以我决定满足这个愿望。
All right, that's kind of true. OK. So I'm really psyched and I'm thinking, OK, maybe if we go to Paris we can work on our, you know--
好吧，那算是有几分真实。行。所以我真的很兴奋，我想，好吧，如果我们去巴黎，也许我们可以解决我们的，你知道——
Malaise.
不安感。
--malaise. So the next thing we know, we're in Paris. And it's better than I ever thought it could be. The light was amazing, and the architecture's amazing.
——不安感。所以接下来我们就在巴黎了。这比我想象的还要好。光线太棒了，建筑也太棒了。
The food.
美食。
The art, the food. It was wonderful.
艺术，美食。真是太美妙了。
But where's [? Malika ?], the person that was going to give us the apartment to stay in?
但[马利卡]在哪？那个要把公寓借给我们住的人呢？
She's nowhere to be found. And we call her apartment, and they say the number's disconnected. So we get a hotel room on the Left Bank. And I'm just really overly excited. And one day on our way to the Eiffel Tower, we go through the Jardin du Luxembourg, which is a beautiful park. And out of the corner of my eye, I see chess tables. And like we said before, he's a chess master. He's a national master. He's in the top 1% of the United States. So the last thing I want to see is a chess table.
她不见踪影。我们给她公寓打电话，他们说电话号码已注销。所以我们在左岸开了一间酒店房。我简直太兴奋了。有一天在去埃菲尔铁塔的路上，我们穿过了卢森堡花园，那是一个美丽的公园。我眼角余光看到了棋桌。像我们之前说的，他是国际象棋大师。他是国家大师。他在美国属于前1%的顶尖行列。所以我最不想看到的就是棋桌。
So I tell him, "Look, Candido, look at the puppet show over there. Isn't that really great? All these little kids. Look, tennis courts. Wow, there's so many things to do in the park--"
所以我对他说，“看，坎迪多，看那边的木偶戏。不是很棒吗？这么多小孩。看，网球场。哇，公园里有这么多事情可以做——”
Look, chess tables over here. Let's go see.
看，这边的棋桌。我们去看看。
So we're in this great romantic city, city of love, and we're supposed to be, you know, trying to reconnect and cure our malaise and he spent all his time in Paris playing chess and I spent my time--
所以我们在这种伟大的浪漫城市，爱之城，我们本该，你知道，试图重新联络并治愈我们的不安感，但他把所有时间都花在巴黎下国际象棋，而我把时间花在——
Going to museums, stuff like that. Who cares?
去博物馆，那种事。谁在乎呢？
Then it's time to go to the wedding.
然后到了去婚礼的时候。
The week passes and we take a train overnight to Paris.
一周过去了，我们坐通宵火车去巴黎。
Modena.
摩德纳（Modena）。
To Modena. Excuse me. But we get to Modena, and her friend, we call her, and she says, yeah, I'll be there in 25 minutes. Comes to pick us up in three hours. And I saw that as a sign that we shouldn't be there. We should be in Paris where I could be playing chess. And Carmen didn't want to go back.
去摩德纳。抱歉。但我们到了摩德纳，给她朋友打电话，她说，好的，我25分钟后到。结果三小时后才来接我们。我把这看作一个我们不该在那里的信号。我们应该在巴黎，我可以在那下棋。而卡门不想回去。
Because I knew that as soon as we got back to Paris, he would play chess. I was like, no way. I want a vacation. We're going to be here in Italy. We're going to support my friend. I don't want to hear the word chess.
因为我知道一旦我们回到巴黎，他就会下棋。我当时心想，没门。我想要假期。我们要在这里参加意大利的婚礼。我们要支持我的朋友。我不想再听到“国际象棋”这几个字。
So her friend lives like-- we thought she lived in the city but she really lives like in Arkansas. Cow country. So now we get stuck in this house in Arkansas.
结果她朋友住在像——我们以为她住在城里，但她实际上住在阿肯色州那种地方。牛乡。所以现在我们被困在阿肯色州的这所房子里。
Formigene.
福米吉内（Formigene）。
Formigene. And she drops us there with her non-English, Spanish speaking parents and she leaves to the country house. And leaves us there.
福米吉内。她把我们丢在那里，和她只会说西班牙语、不懂英语的父母在一起，然后她就去了乡下的房子。把我们留在那。
And then she cancels the wedding. And she decides not even to tell her parents that she's married. So we spend that week alone with her parents.
然后她取消了婚礼。她决定甚至不告诉父母她已经结婚了。所以我们和她父母独自度过了一周。
It wasn't that bad.
其实没那么糟。
Because they were pretty nice.
因为他们挺好的。
We got drunk a couple of times.
我们还喝醉了几次。
On liquor made out of chestnuts, and they were very nice to us. But he's complaining again, there's no chess. Everything's old, it looks like a tomb. I'm upset, there's no chess players here. I want to leave.
喝的是栗子酒，他们对我们很好。但他又在抱怨，没棋下。一切都破破烂烂，像个坟墓。我很不高兴，这里没有棋手。我想走。
I get claustrophobic, you know. We start fighting more and more.
我有幽闭恐惧症，你知道。我们开始吵得越来越厉害。
So we start fighting more and more. My friend asks me if I support her decision about this wedding. I tell her, no. I mean, you know, you're 35 years old, you should tell your parents you're married. And so she's mad at me. So she stops talking to me. Him and I have one of the hugest fights, and we break up. And he says, "You know what?"
所以我们吵得越来越厉害。我朋友问我是否支持她这个婚礼的决定。我告诉她，不支持。我是说，你看，你都35岁了，你应该告诉父母你已经结婚了。她对我生气了。所以她不再跟我说话。我和他大吵了一架，我们分手了。他说，“你知道吗？”
I'm going back to Paris.
我要回巴黎。
And I'm like, go. I'm like, go, but I have all the passports. I take care of the tickets. I'm the one that made all the phone calls in French and Italian. So I tell him, OK, if you can figure out on your own how to get back to Paris, you can go. So he couldn't figure out how to get back, so he stayed with me.
我当时说，走啊。我说，走啊，但我拿着所有的护照。我负责处理机票。我是那个用法文和意大利文打电话的人。所以我告诉他，好，如果你能自己想办法回巴黎，你就走吧。结果他想不出怎么回去，所以他留在了我身边。
I knew how to go back. I just didn't know how to speak the language to get back, you know.
我知道怎么回去。我只是不知道怎么说那种语言去回去，你知道。
OK. All right. So the next stage of this whole trip is to go to Corsica. And we had made plans, so we all go. So my friend is mad. They're fighting and we're fighting. And we wind up in Corsica.
行吧。好吧。所以这次旅行的下一站是去科西嘉岛（Corsica）。我们早就计划好了，所以我们都去了。我朋友很生气。他们吵架，我们也在吵。最后我们到了科西嘉。
Now Corsica, I don't know if you've been there but it's like the ugliest place I've ever been to. It's these ugly rocks coming out from the ground. And so I'm not really happy here. And I'm feeling more and more claustrophobic because now I'm in another country. So we drive down and we turn a mountain and we go to the south of, um--
科西嘉，我不知道你有没有去过，但那是我去过最丑的地方。从地上突出的丑陋岩石。所以我在这里并不开心。我感到越来越幽闭恐惧，因为我身处另一个国家。我们开车下山，拐过一座山，去了南边，嗯——
Corsica.
科西嘉。
Corsica which is Bonifacio.
科西嘉，就是博尼法乔（Bonifacio）。
Bonifacio, it's the southernmost city.
博尼法乔，它是最南端的城市。
And they turned and we come up into this beautiful town. And the other people, they went camping. So we wouldn't go camping with them because I don't camp in New York. You know. I'm not traveling across the world to go camping. So they get very angry at us, of course. You know, that's another thing to be angry about. And we get to Bonifacio and it's, like, one of the most beautiful places I've ever been to.
他们转过弯，我们来到这个美丽的城镇。其他人去露营了。我们才不跟他们一起露营，因为我在纽约都不露营。你知道。我不是为了露营而横跨世界旅行的。当然，他们对我们很生气。你知道，那又是另一件值得生气的事。我们到了博尼法乔，它是我去过最美的地方之一。
It's built into the rock, but it looks like Monaco. It has those kind of lights. It's very romantic. And our friend drops us off in our hotel and she goes, "Well, I'll see you next week." And she just drives off.
它建在岩石中，但看起来像摩纳哥。它有那种灯光。非常浪漫。朋友把我们送到酒店说，“好吧，下周见。”然后她就开车走了。
Now, we don't have work, we don't have chess, we don't have her friend. All we have left between us is our general malaise.
现在，我们没有工作，没有棋，没有朋友。我们之间剩下的只有普遍的不安感。
We start-- first, we're not really talking to each other and he's really upset. He's like, you know, this really sucks. I can't believe that you did this to me. I could have been in Paris. But then we start taking walks. I mean, there's really not much else to do and, so--
我们开始——起初，我们真的不说话，他很不爽。他像，你知道，这真是太糟了。我不敢相信你对我做了这种事。我本来可以在巴黎的。但后来我们开始散步。我是说，真的没别的事可做，所以——
One morning.
有一天早上。
There's a beautiful prehistoric town, and we start kind of connecting and talking about the history. One morning we're eating breakfast in a beautiful restaurant that's built into the rock. And it's a very clear day. And we're on the patio. And you can see Sardinia. And it dawned on me, wow, we're two Puerto Ricans from the Bronx and we're here and we see Sardinia and this beautiful day. And I look over to Candido and I'm like, wow, I'm really glad I'm sharing this with him.
有一个美丽的史前城镇，我们开始产生共鸣，谈论历史。有一天早上，我们在一家建在岩石里的漂亮餐馆吃早餐。那是个非常晴朗的天气。我们在露台上。可以看到撒丁岛。我恍然大悟，哇，我们是来自布朗克斯的两个波多黎各人，我们在这里，看到了撒丁岛和这美好的一天。我看向坎迪多，感觉，哇，我很高兴能和他分享这一切。
I was feeling the same way.
我的感觉也是一样。
So Sunday morning was the seventh day. She calls and she says, OK, be downstairs in 20 minutes. We go downstairs, 20 minutes, she comes and we get back in the car. And it took 12 hours to get back to Formigine. Because there's a long ride, there's a ferry, and then there's another long ride in Italy. And in those 12 hours nobody said a word. And she was really upset.
所以周日早上是第七天。她打电话说，好的，20分钟后在楼下等。我们下楼，20分钟后她来了，我们坐回车里。花了12个小时才回到福米吉内。因为路很长，还要渡轮，然后意大利境内还有一段很长的路。在那12个小时里谁都没说话。她真的很不高兴。
And we're kind of feeling good, but we're just reading the vibe and we're like, OK, we shouldn't say anything.
我们感觉还好，但我们只是在感知氛围，我们心想，好吧，我们什么都不该说。
The next morning we pack. And we're supposed to be leaving about 4:00 to catch the 5 o'clock train. And somewhere about 12 o'clock she calls Carmen over.
第二天早上我们打包。我们本该在大约4点离开赶5点的火车。在12点左右，她把卡门叫过去。
She wants to talk to me privately. And she brings me into this office in her-- she has a really big house. And she says, I'm really mad at you because you didn't talk to me on the way back from Corsica. I don't know what's up with you.
她想私下跟我谈谈。她把我带进她办公室，她有一个非常大的房子。她说，我真的很生你的气，因为你从科西嘉回来的路上没跟我说话。我不知道你搞什么鬼。
You didn't go camping.
你没去露营。
You didn't go camping with me. You went to Paris first. And you said you were going to come here earlier. But then you were here too long in my house and you used the washing machine. Like, oh my god, make up your mind. If you're upset at me, just pick something. I was so confused. And then it dawned on me kind of, you know, this is not the friendship I thought it was. And I'm like, well, you know what? I'm not going to deal with this. I'm out of here. She was like, fine, get out of my house right now. So I go get Candido, in the back yard studying chess.
你没跟我去露营。你先去了巴黎。而且你说你早该来的。但你又在我家住了太久，还用了洗衣机。天呐，你下定决心吧。如果你生我的气，就挑一件事。我太困惑了。然后我恍然大悟，你知道，这不是我以为的那种友谊。我心想，好吧，你知道吗？我不想处理这个了。我走了。她就像，行，现在就滚出我的房子。所以我去后院把坎迪多叫上，他在那研究象棋。
I carry my chess books with me.
我随身带着我的棋谱。
He has a chess book.
他有本棋谱。
My chess board.
我的棋盘。
But, you know, we're happy so I don't feel like a chess widow anymore, so it's OK. So I go tell him we have to leave.
但是，你知道，我们很幸福，所以我再也不觉得像个“象棋寡妇”了，所以没关系。所以我去告诉他我们必须走了。
So we pack. And as we're packing-- and I know something's going to happen because we have to have that blow up, you know? We go outside, and there's a black cloud right on top of the house. And it starts to rain on top of the house. It wasn't raining any other place. There was sun all over the place, except on top of the house. So I said OK, this is the universe playing a trick on us or God laughing at us.
所以我们打包。当我们打包时——我知道会发生什么，因为我们得爆发一下，你知道？我们走出去，房子上方有一团乌云。开始在房子上方下雨。其他地方都没下雨。到处都是太阳，除了房子上方。所以我说好吧，这是宇宙在捉弄我们，或者上帝在嘲笑我们。
And her mother says, take them to the train station.
她妈妈说，送他们去火车站。
Her mother doesn't know anything.
她妈妈什么都不知道。
So I know we're not going to make it to the train station because in the car we are going to blows. So she takes the back roads down the tomato fields and she begins to berate us.
所以我知道我们赶不上火车，因为在车里我们会爆发冲突。所以她走西红柿田里的后路下山，开始责骂我们。
She starts arguing. She just rehashes the whole argument all over again and how we couldn't make it on our own to the train station.
她开始争论。她把整个争吵又重演了一遍，关于我们怎么没法自己去火车站。
You're so smart, why don't you make it on your own?
你这么聪明，怎么不自己走呢？
And we had just done it before--
我们之前刚做过——
I'm in Arkansas, that's why.
我是在阿肯色州，这就是原因。
That's true. So she says, if you don't let me speak, I'm going to throw you out of the car.
那是真的。所以她说，如果你不让我说话，我就把你赶下车。
So we said, throw us out.
所以我们说，赶我们下去。
Throw us out.
赶我们下去。
Which she did.
她真的照做了。
She gets out of the car. She takes all our bags out--
她下车。她把我们所有的行李都拿出来——
Throws them in the street.
扔在大街上。
She's like, get out of here, I never want to see you again.
她像，滚，我再也不想见到你们了。
Stops traffic. I mean, there's like 50 cars now looking at us. People getting out of the cars.
拦住了交通。我是说，有大约50辆车在看着我们。人们纷纷下车。
And leaves us with our bags, walking down this road.
然后把我们和行李留在路边，走下这条路。
But we have a cart. So we put all the bags in the cart. And suddenly, we feel free.
但我们有一个手推车。所以我们把所有的包都放进推车里。突然间，我们感到自由了。
We start laughing.
我们开始大笑。
We start laughing. And we never felt so free in this three weeks. It was like five miles away from the train station. As we walk down this straight, narrow road I started thinking about the soldiers in World War II when the war was over. And they were going home and they had won the war. And Carmen and I are walking--
我们开始大笑。这是三周来我们从未感到如此自由。离火车站大约还有五英里。当我们走在狭窄的直路上时，我开始想到二战时的士兵，战争结束时。他们回家了，他们赢得了战争。卡门和我在走——
We looked at each other, and we talked about that, this war that we'd just been through. And it just felt so peaceful and--
我们看着彼此，谈论着那场我们刚刚经历的战争。感觉如此平静，并且——
So right.
如此正确。
I fell in love again. It was really beautiful.
我再次坠入爱河。这真的很美。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
Carmen Rivera and Candido Tirado told their story during an evening of traveling stories held by The Moth. They're playwrights. Both of them have plays running at the Spanish Repertory Theater in New York.
卡门·里维拉和坎迪多·蒂拉多在“飞蛾”（The Moth）举办的旅行故事之夜讲述了他们的故事。他们是剧作家。他们两人都有戏剧在纽约西班牙话剧团上演。
Coming up, martinis every day, El Producto cigars, no fresh fruit or vegetables, and four high school cheerleaders. That's what you get when your job is one long road trip and you are the 92-year-old George Burns. We have an eyewitness account. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，每天的马提尼，El Producto雪茄，没有新鲜水果或蔬菜，还有四个高中拉拉队长。这就是当你的工作是一段漫长的公路旅行，而你是92岁的乔治·伯恩斯时所得到的。我们有一个目击者的叙述。一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, as our nation heads out on the road for the Memorial Day weekend, Road Trip, the pleasures and disappointments of life on the road. We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, On the Road in a Tuxedo.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请不同的作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，随着我们国家在阵亡将士纪念日周末踏上旅程，“公路旅行”，在路上的快乐与失望。我们进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，穿着燕尾服上路。
There are two ways you feel when you interview a celebrity. There are those that make you feel like a person. Then there are the kind who make you feel like a blip. There's nothing wrong with a blip interview. In fact, it's liberating. You can say whatever you want to them. They will not remember you.
采访名人的时候有两种感受。有一种是让你感觉自己像个人。还有一种是让你感觉自己像个“小插曲”（blip）。那种小插曲式的采访也没什么不好。事实上，这是一种解脱。你可以对他们说任何你想说的话。他们不会记得你。
10 years ago reporter Margy Rochlin was sent to do a magazine story about George Burns. For a 92-year-old, he was spending a lot of time on the road. 25 shows a year at conventions and other one night gigs. Plus weeklong stints in Vegas and Atlantic City.
10年前，记者玛吉·罗克林被派去写一篇关于乔治·伯恩斯的杂志报道。对于一个92岁的老人来说，他当时在路上奔波的时间太长了。每年要在会议和其他单场演出中做25场表演。加上在拉斯维加斯和大西洋城为期一周的驻场演出。
This is the story of a road trip as business not pleasure. George's entourage in its entirety at that time included Irving Fein, his then 77-year-old manager, and Morty Jacobs, his piano player for, at that time, 23 years.
这就是一个作为工作而非享乐的公路旅行故事。当时乔治的随行人员包括欧文·费恩（Irving Fein），他当时77岁的经纪人，以及莫蒂·雅各布斯（Morty Jacobs），他当时做了23年的钢琴伴奏。
From the start it was clear to Margy, they were kind men, they were polite men. They called her "kid" the way they called everybody "kid." They reminded her a lot of some of her older Jewish relatives. But this was a blip story.
从一开始玛吉就很清楚，他们是善良的人，是有礼貌的人。他们叫她“孩子”（kid），就像叫所有人那样。他们让她想起了她的一些年长的犹太亲戚。但这只是一个小插曲式的报道。
9 o'clock Friday night, Moscow, Idaho. University Inn. We sit around in the common living room that connects George and Irving's bedrooms. George and Irving always get connected bedrooms, with a living room in between if they can. In the late afternoon when it's quiet, this is where George and Irving like to sit. They watch television. They read the trades.
周五晚上9点，爱达荷州莫斯科。大学酒店。我们坐在连接乔治和欧文卧室的公共起居室里。乔治和欧文总是订连通房，如果可以的话，中间还有一个起居室。傍晚安静的时候，这就是乔治和欧文喜欢坐着的地方。他们看电视。他们阅读贸易报刊。
Right now Morty's here. The sun is set and it's early evening. In general, they have three main topics of conversation, the act, the schedule, and where they want to eat. Here's some typical dialogue. Morty will say, "Where should we eat?" And Irving will say, "The Broiler Room." That's the hotel steakhouse. And then George will say, "John will know." John's the handler who picked us up at the airport and drove us to the hotel. And then Irving will say, "I think we should do the Broiler Room." And then George will say, "John will know. Ask John." And then Irving will say, "I'm making a reservation at the Broiler Room." But not moved towards the telephone. And on and on and on. It's like dialogue that David Mamet would write if David Mamet wrote scenes where absolutely nothing was at stake.
现在莫蒂也在这。太阳落山了，天色渐晚。总的来说，他们有三个主要的谈话主题：演出、时间表，以及想去哪里吃饭。这是典型的对话。莫蒂会说，“我们去哪吃？”欧文会说，“烧烤室（The Broiler Room）。”那是酒店的牛排馆。然后乔治会说，“约翰会知道的。”约翰是接送我们去机场并开车送我们去酒店的随行人员。然后欧文会说，“我想我们应该去烧烤室。”然后乔治会说，“约翰会知道。问约翰去。”然后欧文会说，“我在烧烤室订个位。”但却没有移动去打电话。如此往复。这就像大卫·马梅特（David Mamet）会写的对话，如果他写那种完全无关紧要的场景的话。
We head down to the Broiler Room. All through dinner there's this constant traffic of fans, including at one point four cheerleaders. They're wearing short skirts and tight sweaters and their nervous energy fills the room. "Go, George, Go!" they scream over and over again while they shake and wiggle and do air splits and rattle their crepe paper pom poms. Then, floor show over, they run out in a single file as if everything they do is part of a routine.
我们前往烧烤室。整个晚餐过程中，粉丝们川流不息，包括其中有四个拉拉队长。她们穿着短裙和紧身毛衣，那种紧张的能量充斥着整个房间。“乔治，加油！”她们一遍又一遍地尖叫，同时摇晃、扭动、做着劈叉动作，舞动着她们的拉拉队彩带。然后，表演结束，她们排成一列跑了出去，仿佛她们所做的一切都是例行公事的一部分。
Then in comes the chef to ask for George's autograph. But George Burns likes these intrusions. He's nourished by them. When it's finally quite he says to me, "Aren't people nice?"
然后主厨进来索要乔治的签名。但乔治·伯恩斯喜欢这种打扰。他从中汲取营养。当终于安静下来时，他对我说道：“人们难道不友善吗？”
Because I'm a reporter, I'm a blip. But the public gets his full attention. He establishes eye contact with each approaching fan and he smiles at them and he asks how they're doing. And when he leaves the Broiler Room, he'll choose the most complicated route, slowly threading his way through the tables of the main dining room, touching people on the shoulder lightly, and saying things like, "Don't pay the check."
因为我是个记者，我只是个小插曲。但公众得到了他的全神贯注。他与每一个走过来的粉丝进行眼神交流，对他们微笑，并问他们好。当他离开烧烤室时，他会选择最复杂的路线，慢慢穿过主餐厅的桌子，轻轻拍拍人们的肩膀，说着诸如“别结账了”之类的话。
It's nice to be here. It's nice to be anywhere.
能来到这里真好。能到任何地方都真好。
While we're on the road I probably see him do his act five times. Each time it sounds totally spontaneous, like he's making it up right there, just riffing for the crowd, even though, give or take a gag or two, it's the exact same act he's been doing for 15 years.
在路上我大概看了他表演五次。每次听起来都完全是即兴的，就像他在现场现编的一样，对着观众信口开河，尽管除了一两个笑话的变动之外，这和他过去15年来演的完全一样。
And thank you for that standing ovation. But it made me nervous. See, as a rule, an entertainer gets a standing ovation at the end of the show. You were afraid I wouldn't last that long.
谢谢你们的起立鼓掌。但这让我紧张。因为按规矩，艺人在演出结束时才会获得起立鼓掌。你们是怕我活不到那个时候吗。
What's amazing about all this is that on the surface the act doesn't seem to vary from city to city. But to George it's an eternal work in progress. Every night he makes microscopic changes. Maybe he'll decide to sing "Young at Heart" before "Old Bones." When he does this, he gets all worked up about it, thinks about it all day long. But this is how he's been able to be on the road for so long. This is how he keeps the act feeling fresh for himself.
这一切令人惊奇的是，从表面上看，他的演出在不同城市之间似乎并没有什么变化。但对乔治来说，这是一个永恒的“进行中”的作品。每天他都会做微小的改动。也许他会决定在《Old Bones》之前唱《Young at Heart》。当他这么做时，他会变得非常激动，整天都在思考它。但这就是他能在路上坚持这么久的原因。这就是他保持演出对自己而言感觉新鲜的方式。
Sometimes he'll change a punchline. He has a gag in his act about people having to retire when they're 70. He says, "When I was 70, I had pimples." But one day George tries out a new line on me. He says, "When I was 70, I had cupid's eczema." I think that sounds sort of dirty, but I'm not going to be the one to tell him. In fact, I have tape of this, of myself lying to the nicest man on earth.
有时他会改一个包袱。他在演出中有一个关于人们必须在70岁时退休的梗。他说，“我70岁时，脸上还有粉刺。”但有一天乔治试着跟我说了个新台词。他说，“我70岁时，患上了丘比特湿疹（cupid's eczema）。”我觉得那听起来有点下流，但我可不想做那个去告诉他的人。事实上，我录了音，记录下我欺骗了地球上最善良的人。
What would you think that is, cupid's eczema?
你觉得那是什么，丘比特湿疹？
Is that like, I don't know, young--
那是像，我不知道，年轻的——
It doesn't sound dirty, does it?
它听起来不脏，是吧？
No.
不。
Good. OK. That's all.
好。行。就这样。
Is it?
是吗？
No. It's not supposed to be.
不。它不应该脏。
Oh. No it doesn't sound dirty.
哦。不，它听起来不脏。
When I was 70 I had cupid's eczema.
我70岁时患上了丘比特湿疹。
Well, that is dirty.
嗯，那是下流的。
It isn't dirty. You're making it dirty. You don't know what cupid's eczema is. It could be anything.
它不脏。是你把它变脏了。你根本不知道什么是丘比特湿疹。它可以是任何东西。
Well, eczema is a--
嗯，湿疹是一种——
A rash.
皮疹。
A rash. And cupid is the love. It's a love rash.
皮疹。而丘比特是爱情。这是一种“爱情疹”。
OK. A love rash. What's dirty about a love rash?
行。爱情疹。爱情疹有什么脏的？
That's true.
那是真的。
George and Irving can go on like this for hours. They go back and forth and back and forth. And that night, George tries out the cupid's eczema line. It doesn't get laughs. On the way home in the car we're silent. George and a driver in the front. Me in the back, squeezed hip to elbow between Irving and Morty. Suddenly, George's rumbling voice cuts through the darkness. "I'll never do that again," he says. It's quiet for a while more. "Morty," he says, "tomorrow night let's--" and then the conversation starts all over again.
乔治和欧文可以这样持续几个小时。他们来回交谈。那天晚上，乔治尝试了丘比特湿疹的台词。没收到笑声。在回家的车里，我们沉默不语。乔治和司机在前座。我坐在后座，被挤在欧文和莫蒂之间，肘部紧贴着。突然，乔治低沉的声音穿透了黑暗。“我再也不会那么做了，”他说。安静了一会儿。“莫蒂，”他说，“明晚我们……”然后对话又重新开始了。
Normally when I think of going on the road, I think of waking up at any hour, of not having to be anywhere at a certain time. You're on a big adventure. The rules no longer apply. There's no accountability. But that's a civilian's road trip. I am on a very different kind of road trip.
通常当我想到上路时，我会想到随时起床，不需要在特定时间出现在特定地点。你正在进行一场大冒险。规则不再适用。没有任何责任。但那是普通人的公路旅行。我进行的是一种非常不同的公路旅行。
The road trip I'm on is not about adventure and unpredictability. The road trip I'm on is about making sure that everything is the same. This is the secret to George Burns' longevity, of how he's been able to stay on the road for so long without going crazy. He wakes up at a certain time. He goes to sleep at a certain time.
我进行的这次公路旅行不是关于冒险和不可预测性。我的公路旅行是关于确保一切都保持不变。这就是乔治·伯恩斯长寿的秘诀，他是如何能在路上坚持这么久而没发疯的。他在特定时间起床。他在特定时间睡觉。
When he goes on the road, he likes his driver to take him to the airport in the late morning. When he agrees to a booking it's stipulated in his contract that he'll be provided with a backless stool to sit on, a lightly rehearsed orchestra, an ashtray to flick his ashes in, and a pre-show speed ball made up of a couple of martinis chased by a cup of black coffee. He will only smoke El Productos. In the afternoon he likes to take a two hour nap. He hates fresh fruit and vegetables.
当他上路时，他喜欢让司机在上午晚些时候送他去机场。当他同意预订时，合同中规定他必须提供一把靠背椅、一个稍微排练过的管弦乐队、一个用来弹烟灰的烟灰缸，以及演出前的一杯混合饮料，由几杯马提尼加上一杯黑咖啡组成。他只抽El Producto雪茄。在下午，他喜欢小睡两个小时。他讨厌新鲜水果和蔬菜。
By the end of our time together, I could order for him in a restaurant if necessary. He likes bay shrimp cocktails. He likes roast chicken. He likes his martinis, but doesn't care what brand of liquor they're made with. He just wants them to come one after the other. He is 92 and no one can tell him what is good or bad for him to put in his own mouth. Same goes for what comes out of it.
在我们相处的最后，如果必要的话，我可以在餐厅为他点餐。他喜欢海湾虾鸡尾酒。他喜欢烤鸡。他喜欢他的马提尼，但不在乎它们是用什么牌子的酒做的。他只是想一杯接一杯。他已经92岁了，没人能告诉他什么对他的嘴有好处或坏处。他嘴里说出来的话也是一样。
As the gin and vermouth kick in, his conversation tends to get naughty. One night he recites to me a particularly memorable limerick that involves a mouse, the phrase "hickory dickory dock" and a reference to his own private parts. Morty and Irving laugh, but I don't know what to do. If I laugh too hard, I'm scared they're going to think I'm some sort of slut girl. And if I don't, then I'm a pill, no fun at all. I feel as if I'm in another country with different customs and mores, and so I simply try every possible reaction one after the other, laughing, groaning, shaking my head, waiting for something that works.
随着琴酒和苦艾酒起效，他的谈话趋向于下流。有一天晚上，他给我背诵了一首令人难忘的打油诗，涉及一只老鼠，“hickory dickory dock”这个短语，以及对自己私处的引用。莫蒂和欧文笑了，但我不知道该怎么办。如果我笑得太大声，我怕他们会以为我是个轻浮的女孩。如果我不笑，我又成了一个乏味、一点乐趣都没有的人。我感觉自己好像在另一个有着不同习俗和道德准则的国家，所以我只是尝试每一个可能的反应，笑、呻吟、摇头，等待着什么起作用。
The pace is very slow. I wake up in the morning, drink coffee, wait for Irving's call. Mostly I have free time. I lay on a variety of queen-sized beds in a variety of shag carpet hotel rooms and stare up at the ceiling.
节奏非常缓慢。我早上起床，喝咖啡，等欧文的电话。大多时候我有空闲时间。我躺在各种酒店房间的各种大床上，盯着天花板看。
One day Irving calls to invite me to talk to George as he eats breakfast.
有一天欧文打电话邀请我和乔治在他吃早餐时谈话。
You want something, kid?
你要吃点什么吗，孩子？
Nah. I'm just going to--
不了。我只是要——
I could have ordered something for you.
我本来可以帮你点些东西的。
It's OK. I already had breakfast.
没关系。我已经吃过早餐了。
You did, eh?
你吃过了，嘿？
Yes, I did.
是的，吃过了。
Did you do your cereal already, George?
你吃过麦片了吗，乔治？
No. I don't know if I can do the cereal.
不。我不知道我能不能吃下麦片。
You can do the cereal, George.
你可以吃下麦片，乔治。
George is wearing a thick beige terry cloth bathrobe, beige pajamas, and slippers. His stiff grey toupee is somewhere in the other room. It's startling to see the man that lives underneath the hair, the stacked heeled shoes, the crisp tuxedo. He looks vulnerable, bird like.
乔治穿着一件厚厚的米色毛巾浴袍，米色睡衣，穿着拖鞋。他那僵硬的灰色假发在另一个房间。看到那头假发、高跟鞋、挺括燕尾服下那个真正的男人，真是令人震惊。他看起来很脆弱，像只鸟。
I have this realization. This will be a man who I will get to know in the moments between words. Even on a road trip designed to avoid surprises, I find myself surprised by these men. My view of them comes to change as we spend more time together.
我有了这个感悟。这将是一个我会在只言片语之间了解的男人。即使在旨在避免意外的公路旅行中，我也发现自己被这些人所惊讶。随着我们相处的时间变长，我对他们的看法开始改变。
11:00 AM. Reno, Nevada, Bally's hotel. I'm trying to keep my focus, but I'm tired. Tired of the empty hours, tired of waiting for Irving to call. Whenever I call my boyfriend, his answering machine picks up. Finally I take the elevator to the hotel casino. I play the slot machines, mindlessly pulling down the handle. Somehow Irving finds me. I'm playing the quarter slots. I'm risking a grand total of $10, but he's positive that I will return home having handed over the title to my car. He goes away, then comes back and tells me it's time to quit. He goes away, then comes back 15 minutes later and tells me again. I'm annoyed at his nagging, and touched. To save me from financial ruin, he asks me to take a walk with him.
上午11点。内华达州里诺，巴利酒店（Bally's）。我试图保持专注，但我很累。厌倦了空虚的时光，厌倦了等待欧文打电话。每当我给男朋友打电话，他的答录机就会响起。最后我乘电梯去酒店赌场。我玩老虎机，机械地拉下手柄。不知何故欧文找到了我。我正在玩25美分的机器。我冒着总共10美元的风险，但他非常确信我回家时会交出我的车钥匙。他走开了，然后又回来告诉我该停下了。他走开，15分钟后又回来告诉了我一次。我被他的唠叨弄得很烦，但也感到很感动。为了把我从财务破产中拯救出来，他让我和他一起去散步。
Irving takes my hand and loops it past his bent elbow. Arm in arm, we stroll past places with names like The Mapes Hotel and the Liberty Bell Saloon. The way Irving is almost bouncing down the street lets me know he's enjoying that we come off like a mismatched couple, that I'm his babe and he is my silver-haired, energetic sugar daddy.
欧文牵着我的手，把它绕过他弯曲的手肘。我们手挽手，走过像梅普斯酒店（The Mapes Hotel）和自由钟酒吧（Liberty Bell Saloon）之类名字的地方。欧文几乎是蹦蹦跳跳地走在街上，这让我知道他很享受我们看起来像是一对不般配的伴侣，我是他的宝贝，而他是我的银发、精力充沛的干爹。
Most of the time Irving does the talking. He tells me about his past. It's a history of 20th century show business, big jobs at CBS radio, in the movie studios. Jack Benny hired him to be the president of his production company. It's a long story. Every once in awhile, though, Irving asks me personal questions about my family, about my friends, about my boyfriend. And then we head back to the hotel.
大部分时间是欧文在说话。他告诉我他的过去。那是20世纪演艺圈的历史，在哥伦比亚广播公司电台、在电影制片厂担任大职。杰克·本尼（Jack Benny）雇他担任他制作公司的总裁。这是一个很长的故事。不过，偶尔欧文会问我一些关于我的家庭、朋友、男朋友的私人问题。然后我们就回酒店了。
And when we get to my room, he drops me off with this thought. He says, "Leave your boyfriend. He's no good. Find someone else." And he walks away, and I stand there feeling conflicted. I think, I'm no longer a blip to Irving, but who does he think he is? He doesn't know me. He's never met my boyfriend. A couple of years later I foll his advice. And every once in awhile I think back, trying to remember what it was that I said to him, what allowed him to distill this conclusion from my small talk. How come he knew something that took so long for me to figure out?
当我们回到我房间时，他留下了一个念头。他说，“离开你的男朋友。他不好。找别人吧。”然后他走开了，我站在那里感到矛盾。我想，对于欧文来说我不再是个小插曲了，但他以为他是谁？他不了解我。他从未见过我的男朋友。几年后我遵循了他的建议。偶尔我会回想起这件事，试着记住我对他说了什么，是什么让他从我的闲聊中提炼出这个结论。为什么他知道一些我花这么久才明白的事情？
All I could come up with was how transparent I must have seemed to these men. Transparent like teenagers are to me. I mean, how many different human stories are there? These men had already been there.
我唯一能想到的是，在这些人面前我看起来是多么透明。就像十几岁的孩子在我面前那样透明。我是说，世界上有多少种不同的人生故事？这些人早就经历过了。
Finally, we are on the road for so long that George is treating me like old news, which is where you want to be with George. When Irving lets me into George's suite before a show, George emerges from his room wearing shiny patent leather loafers, a crisp white shirt, a bow tie, and a knee-length paisley dressing down. He is pantless. He doesn't want to put on his tuxedo slacks until the very last minute so they don't lose their knife-sharp crease.
最后，我们在路上待了太久，乔治开始把我当成“老新闻”对待，这就是你想和乔治达到的状态。当欧文在演出前让我进入乔治的套房时，乔治从他的房间里出来，穿着光亮的漆皮便鞋，一件挺括的白衬衫，打着领结，穿着一件膝盖长度的佩斯利花纹晨袍。他没穿裤子。他不想穿他的燕尾服裤子，直到最后一刻，以免它们失去那如刀锋般锐利的折痕。
In the pocket of these pants is a watch chain. On the watch chain is Gracie's tiny gold wedding ring. The way he tells the story of their marriage is that he discovered his one true talent when he met Gracie Allen. And he stayed married to her for 38 years. He was the brains of the act, the one who wrote almost every word she said. But she was the one who the public loved. He tells me that since her death in 1964, he visits her once a month at Forest Lawn Cemetery so he can tell her what's been going on in his life. But at first, his need to see her was so great that he'd go every day.
在这条裤子的口袋里有一条表链。表链上挂着格蕾西那枚小小的金婚戒。他讲述自己婚姻的方式是，他是在遇到格蕾西·艾伦时才发现了自己唯一的真正天赋。他和她维持了38年的婚姻。他是表演中的大脑，几乎写下了她说的每一个字。但她才是公众所钟爱的那个人。他告诉我，自从她1964年去世后，他每月去林茵纪念公园墓地看望她一次，这样他就能告诉她自己生活中的近况。但起初，他想见她的渴望如此强烈，以至于他每天都会去。
Tonight he shows me the ring.
今晚他向我展示了那枚戒指。
When Gracie died, it was terrible. Terribly dry. Then finally I started sleeping in Gracie's bed, and that helped a lot. The night where Gracie died, that night, Bobby Darin said to me, George-- Mr. Burns he always called me-- he says, you don't want to sleep alone. Why don't I go home and sleep with you? I says, Bobby I'd love it.
当格蕾西（Gracie）去世时，那太可怕了。极其空虚。最后我开始睡在格蕾西的床上，那帮了大忙。格蕾西去世的那天晚上，鲍比·达林（Bobby Darin）对我说，乔治——他总是叫我伯恩斯先生——他说，你不想独自睡觉。为什么我不回家和你一起睡呢？我说，鲍比，我太乐意了。
That's a wonderful thing to do.
那是一件美妙的事情。
Yeah, he slept with me that night.
是的，他那天晚上和我一起睡了。
But I mean, did it take you a long time to get your life back together?
但我意思是，你花了很长时间才恢复生活吗？
I was shocked when Gracie died. I didn't think Gracie should die. But you can't do anything.
格蕾西去世时我很震惊。我不认为格蕾西应该死。但你无能为力。
So, how long did it take you to get back to work?
那么，你花了多长时间回到工作岗位？
I started to work right away. That got nothing to with it. Show business has got nothing to do with that. You're doing your act. You're making a living. It's a different kind of--
我马上就开始工作。那和那个没关系。演艺事业与那无关。你在做你的演出。你在谋生。那是另一种——
But at that time, you were financially solvent. I mean, you had plenty of money. Wasn't it more just to take your mind off of things?
但当时，你经济状况很好。我是说，你很有钱。那难道不是为了让你分心吗？
I've got plenty of money now and I'm working.
我现在很有钱，我还在工作。
But you enjoy it.
但你享受它。
That's right.
没错。
OK, so at that time was it more to-- what are you going to do? Just sit around.
好吧，所以当时是为了——你还能做什么？只是坐着吗。
What would you do if somebody died? You sit home and cry? How long can you cry? Cry for two hours? You cry. And you cry, and you cry. Finally there are no more tears. Now you go to work. And you feel bad. Every time you come home, you feel bad because Gracie isn't there.
如果有人去世你会做什么？你坐在家里哭？你能哭多久？哭两个小时？你哭。你哭啊，哭啊。最后没有眼泪了。现在你去工作。你会感觉很糟糕。每次你回家，你都会感觉糟糕，因为格蕾西不在那里。
One night, years later, I was sitting in a restaurant in west Los Angeles when I saw George come in. He was with a couple of men and a youngish woman. And they all hovered around him. He had aged so much. He moved slowly and was so tiny that he seemed to be lost inside of the dark suit he was wearing. They all slipped into a red booth and ordered dinner. I think the waiter brought George a martini.
多年后的一天晚上，我坐在西洛杉矶的一家餐馆里，看到乔治进来了。他和几个男人和一个年轻女子在一起。他们都围着他。他老了这么多。他动作缓慢，太瘦小了，以至于看起来迷失在他那件深色西装里。他们都溜进了一个红色卡座点晚餐。我想服务员给乔治拿了一杯马提尼。
When it was time to go, I walked right by him, but I didn't say hello. To George I was always a blip, just another friendly face on the road.
到走的时候，我从他身边走过，但我没打招呼。对于乔治来说，我一直是个小插曲，只是路上又一张友好的面孔。
Margy Rochlin is a magazine writer in Los Angeles.
玛吉·罗克林是洛杉矶的一名杂志作家。
Act Four, Paw Paw for Jesus. So what we want on the road, many of us, is adventure. And what is adventure but a moment or a series of moments that you never could've predicted before you left home?
第四幕，为了耶稣的波波果。所以我们很多人在路上所追求的是冒险。冒险不就是一系列你离开家之前永远无法预料的时刻吗？
We have this story about one such moment from Cheryl Trykv. A warning to listeners with children in their car. This story contains a lot of anti-social behavior.
我们要讲这个故事，来自谢丽尔·特里夫，关于这样一个时刻。给车上有孩子的听众一个警告。这个故事包含很多反社会行为。
It's 1990 and she's wearing a 1977 bleached blond Farrah Fawcett feather do and electric blue Maybelline mascara which contrast nicely with the lime green polyester manager's pantsuit she's got on. And she's telling me, no, not for under $50 dollars a night. Not for under $50 a night will she let me leave my car in the parking lot of her Paw Paw, Michigan Speedway convenience store gas station. This, after an hour and a half of my going in and out, buying chips and juice and cigarettes, wondering what I'm going to do with the Ford Lynx I have borrowed from a friend, which has now got a split valve or something and is busted all to hell and I'm in the middle of goddamn nowhere on the other side of Dowagiac on my way to Kalamazoo for a getaway weekend. I wanted to see America.
那是1990年，她留着1977年的漂白金色法拉·弗西特（Farrah Fawcett）羽毛发型，涂着电光蓝美宝莲睫毛膏，这与她穿着的酸橙绿聚酯纤维经理裤装形成了鲜明对比。她告诉我，不行，少于50美元一晚不行。不到50美元一晚，她绝不让我把车停在她在密歇根州波波果（Paw Paw）的速度便利店加油站停车场。这发生在我进进出出、买薯片、果汁和香烟一个半小时之后，我还在琢磨我该拿我从朋友那借来的那辆福特Lynx怎么办，它现在阀门坏了还是怎么的，烂得要死，我正处于偏远得该死的地方，在道沃贾克（Dowagiac）的另一边，正要去卡拉马祖（Kalamazoo）度个周末。我想看看美国。
I ask her why I can't leave my car in the parking lot. She says it's the rule. I ask who makes the decisions about that rule. She says she does. She says, company policy. Well, whose company is it? She tells me it's her company and she doesn't break the rules. Well, you little [BLEEP] [BLEEP] [BLEEP] can you be a friend, I'm thinking to myself. I don't say it, but boy I'd like to.
我问她为什么我不能把车停在停车场。她说这是规定。我问是谁决定那个规定的。她说她。她说，公司政策。好吧，这是谁的公司？她告诉我这是她的公司，她不破坏规矩。好吧，你这个[哔——]东西，你能做一个朋友吗，我心里想。我没说出来，但我真想说。
Instead I remind her very softly about American hospitality and how Americans are known the world over for their friendly, peaceful, helping nature. I tell her that I noticed on my way in through her charming little town a sweet and simple church with a banner out front that read "Bold yet humble. Paw Paw for Jesus." There are few customers in the store, so I say it again, louder. Paw Paw for Jesus. Paw Paw for Jesus.
相反，我很轻声地提醒她关于美国的待客之道，以及美国人是如何以友好、和平、乐于助人的天性而闻名于世。我告诉她，我在经过她那迷人的小镇时注意到有一座甜美简洁的教堂，前面挂着横幅写着“勇敢而谦逊。为了耶稣的波波果。”店里没几个顾客，所以我又说了一遍，声音更大。“为了耶稣的波波果。为了耶稣的波波果。”
An older gentlemen with an Abraham Lincoln beard and an Elvis Presley coiffe stares at me blankly. The manager tells me to cut the crap and get out of the store. OK, I say to her. I look at her name badge, Mary Ann. I'll get out of your store. But I ain't never coming back to Paw Paw.
一位留着亚伯拉罕·林肯胡子和猫王发型的老先生面无表情地盯着我。经理让我别胡闹，滚出店里。好吧，我对她说。我看了看她的名牌，玛丽·安。我会滚出你的店。但我永远不会再回波波果了。
And I turn and walk away. As I walk away, I accidentally shove my body against a candy bar display case, knocking over hundreds and thousands of Three Musketeers, Reese's, Special Dark, and Snickers. Sweet Tarts fly and spill. A grand gesture of public nuisance. That's it, missus, Mary Ann says from behind the counter. Your big city ass is cooked. I'm calling the police. You idiot, I think to myself on my way out the door. Do I look married to you?
然后我转身走开。当我走开时，我不小心让身体撞向了糖果展示柜，撞倒了成千上万条银河棒（Three Musketeers）、瑞斯（Reese's）、特浓黑巧和士力架。甜挞飞溅开来。一场公开骚乱的盛大举动。就是这样，太太，玛丽·安在柜台后说。你这个大城市来的混蛋完蛋了。我要报警。你这个白痴，我出门时心里想。我看起来像结了婚的吗？
I make it to the highway in no time flat, speed walk backwards with my thumb in the air, calling out to passing cars, Paw Paw for Jesus, Paw Paw for Jesus. A few cars honk and wave, but nobody stops.
我很快就到了公路上，倒着快步走，伸出拇指，对着过往的车辆呼喊，“为了耶稣的波波果，为了耶稣的波波果。”几辆车鸣笛挥手，但没人停车。
I can't imagine it might be what I'm wearing, the same jet black cocktail dress I wore the night before. Maybe my lipstick is too blood red for broad daylight in a small town like Paw Paw. Maybe I just don't seem like I belong here. Finally a van pulls over. It's a Chevy van, one with a mural painted on the side depicting what King Arthur and Guinevere might look like in the year 2500.
我无法想象这可能是我穿的东西，我穿着昨天晚上穿的那件喷气黑鸡尾酒礼服。也许我的口红对于波波果这样的小镇白天来说太血红了。也许我看起来根本就不属于这里。最后，一辆面包车靠边停车了。那是一辆雪佛兰面包车，侧面画着一幅壁画，描绘了亚瑟王和格温娜维尔在2500年可能的样子。
King Arthur wears a gold mesh nuclear cleanup suit. He carries a sword in one hand and a laser gun in the other. Guinevere is nude and amply buxom. Where her pubic hair might be she holds the Holy Grail. The driver leans over and opens the door. It's a man. What a surprise. I get in.
亚瑟王穿着金色的核清理网眼服。他一只手拿着剑，另一只手拿着激光枪。格温娜维尔赤身裸体，胸部丰满。在她可能长阴毛的地方，她拿着圣杯。司机探过身子打开门。是个男人。多么惊喜。我上了车。
He asks how it is he's never seen me before. Maybe because I don't pose nude for Playboy. At the mention of Playboy, he steps on the gas, speeds it to 105. I've never gone 105 in a Chevy van before. it feels pretty good. Faster, I say, and we both start laughing.
他问我为什么他以前从没见过我。也许因为我不为《花花公子》拍裸照。提到《花花公子》，他踩下油门，加速到105英里。我以前从未坐过105英里的雪佛兰面包车。感觉还不错。再快点，我说，我们都开始笑了。
I roll down my window, stick my head out, and yell Paw Paw for Jesus to the wind. I feel like taking off my top, but I don't. Instead I sit back down into the passenger seat, bucket, severely vinyl, light a cigarette and enjoy as best I can the REO Speedwagon tape he's got blasting. He asks me why I'm hitchhiking, and just as he does, a sheriff's car speeds past us on its way back into town. That's why, I say. Cops.
我摇下窗户，把头伸出去，对着风大喊“为了耶稣的波波果”。我想把上衣脱了，但我没脱。相反，我坐回乘客座椅（水桶椅，严重的乙烯基材质），点燃一支烟，尽可能享受他播放的REO Speedwagon磁带。他问我为什么搭便车，就在这时，一辆警车从我们身边飞驰而过，赶回镇上。这就是原因，我说。警察。
What have I got against cops, he wants to know. Nothing, it's just that I'm allergic to pork. It occurs to me at this point to shut up. I really don't know this man and, in all likelihood, he is brother of Mary Ann, manager of the speedway who is daughter of the Sheriff of Paw Paw and that I am headed for a trap.
他想知道我跟警察有什么过节。没什么，我只是对“猪”过敏。此时我想起该闭嘴了。我真的不认识这个男人，很有可能，他是速度便利店经理玛丽·安的兄弟，也就是波波果警长的女儿，而我正在走向一个陷阱。
And in one great, whirling moment of brilliance it becomes very clear to me what I must do and that is sham this vic. It isn't all that difficult. I've seen it in the movies. Just before Treat Williams gets his hair shaved in the woods, Beverly D'angelo steals a four door Ford from an army officer by seducing him down to his underwear. She takes off with this car, his money, and his clothes, which is exactly what I mean to do.
就在那辉煌的闪念时刻，我清楚地知道我必须做什么，那就是骗这个家伙。没那么难。我在电影里见过。就在Treat Williams在树林里被剃头之前，Beverly D'angelo通过诱惑一个陆军军官直到他只剩内衣，偷走了一辆四门福特。她开走了这辆车、他的钱和他的衣服，这正是我想做的。
To prepare myself for this role of a lifetime, I change the tape to "Hotel California." The vic's neck is nasty with sweat, which I ordinarily wouldn't mind. But it has the stale, sweet taste of a flat Mountain Dew. I force myself to enjoy it. By the end of "A Last Resort," "New Kid in Town," "Wasted Time," and "Wasted Time Reprise," he is down to his Fruit of the Loom and I am wearing dark blue corduroy Levis, a Queen concert t-shirt, and a feed cap with an American flag that reads "Try Burning This One Mother[BLEEP]."
为了准备这个我一生中的角色，我把磁带换成了《加州旅馆》。这个家伙的脖子上全是汗，我通常不会介意。但它有一种陈旧、甜腻的平淡激浪饮料的味道。我强迫自己去享受它。在《A Last Resort》、《New Kid in Town》、《Wasted Time》和《Wasted Time Reprise》结束时，他只剩下底裤，而我穿着深蓝灯芯绒Levi's，一件Queen乐队的T恤，还有一顶写着“试着烧掉这一个混蛋”并印有美国国旗的帽子。
Shortly, I create in him the most urgent desire to pull over to the side of the road. And while I'm straddling his lap I somehow open the door with my foot and with my very strong legs kick him out of the van, down onto the asphalt, his stunned, sorry eyes looking up at me in surprise. Did you lose something?
很快，我在他心中激起了停车到路边的最迫切欲望。当我在他腿上骑着时，我不知何故用脚打开了门，用我非常有力的双腿把他踢出了面包车，踢到沥青路面上，他那震惊、可怜的眼睛惊讶地望着我。你丢东西了吗？
30 miles or so up the road I spot a hitch hiker. Hmm, somebody needs a ride. I pull over. She's a frosty little lezebel with a shaved head and a backpack. She asks me where I'm going.
大约30英里外，我发现了一个搭便车的人。嗯，有人需要搭车。我靠边停车。她是一个剃着光头、背着背包的冰冷小恶魔。她问我要去哪。
To hell. Want to come?
去地狱。想来吗？
Cheryl Trykv is a writer here in Chicago.
谢丽尔·特里夫是芝加哥的一名作家。
[MUSIC - "HAPPY TRAILS" BY DAVE DUDLEY]
[音乐 - "HAPPY TRAILS" BY DAVE DUDLEY]
Our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Our senior editor for this show, Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann and Sylvia Lemus.
我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和我制作，还有阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的资深编辑是保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）。特约编辑杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和“顾问”莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。制作协助来自豪尔赫·贾斯特（Jorge Just）、托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和西尔维娅·莱姆斯（Sylvia Lemus）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know, you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买本节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。或者你知道，你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢运行该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight between Torey Malatia who says, yes, call. Pledge all the money you want to public radio. Just be sure--
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他说，是的，打电话。为你想要的公共广播节目捐款。只要确定——
Don't pay the check.
别结账。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI.
PRI。
Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。